autre chose maintenant quatre
braconniers des calanques de marseille
condamné hier à payer 385 milles euros
de dommages et intérêts motif avoir
pêché deux tonnes d'oursins de poupe
notamment dans les zones protégées du
parc national à dépassionner d'apnée
accusé de préjudice écologique causé l
écosystème une pêche illégale qui aurait
pu causer un dérèglement
environnementale selon elle les experts
une décision dont se félicite l'avocat
du parc des calanques en l'écoutant on
nous c'est une très bonne décision nous
sommes très satisfaits c'est la
reconnaissance d'une part de la méthode
d'évaluation qui avait été proposée par
le parquet mais tu as des relations du
préjudice écologique
et c'est la reconnaissance aussi de la
capacité du parc à réparer
l'environnement qui a été impactée que
nous avons proposé une évaluation très
précise du préjudice écologique
c'est-à-dire de de transformer des
éléments parcellaires qui ressortait de
l' enquête sur l'ampleur des prises qui
avait été fait par les par ces
braconniers
nous les extrapoler sur toute la période
de l'avent changera qu'elles étaient
poursuivies c'est-à-dire un peu plus de
quatre ans et ensuite de calcul et c'est
là où où cette décision est nouvelle et
innovante
c'est à dire qu'elle a validé le fait
que l'impact ne se régule pas uniquement
aux individus qui ont été prélevés en de
poissons de poulpe d'oursins mais elle
valide l'impact sur l'ensemble de
l'écosystème